As I mentioned in a fully virtualized setting,
the guest operating system has no idea about machine
pages. It thinks that the physical page number
that it is generating, is the real thing. But
it is not. And therefore, there is two
levels of indirection, one level of indirection going from
virtual page to physical page, that's an illusion. Then
the hypervisor has to take this physical page and
using the shadow page table, convert it into
the machine page. And as I said, the shadow
page table may be the real hardware page
table that the CPU uses as well. So this
is the data structure that is maintained by
the hypervisor to translate the PPN to MPN. So,
how to make this efficient? Because on every memory
access of a process of the guest operating system,
the virtual address has to be converted to a
machine address. So in other words, we want to
avoid the one level of indirection that's happening because
the virtual page number has to be converted to a
physical page number. By the guest operating system and
then it has to be looked up in the
shadow table by the hypervisor to generate the machine
page number. So, we would like to make this process
more efficient because it's happening on every memory
access by getting rid of one level of indirection
that is, this translation by the guest operating system.
Remember that, the guest operating system is the one
that establishes this mapping in the first place
between a virtual page number and a physical page
number. By creating an entry in the page table
for the process that is generating this virtual address
in the first place. And updating the page
table, is a privileged instruction. So, when the
guest operating system tries to update the page
table or what it thinks is the page
table, it'll result in a trap. Any time
the guest operating system tries to update this
page table to establish a mapping between VPN
and PPN, there'll be a trap and this
trap is called by the hypervisor. And
what the hypervisor is going to do is, it's
basically going to say, oh this particular VPN corresponds
to a specific entry in the shadow page
table. So the update that guest OS is making to it's page table data structure,
which it thinks is the real thing. It's
not the real thing. The hypervisor is updating
the same mapping by saying well, this particular VPN
is going to this machine page number, that's the
one that we're going to put as the entry here.
So as a result, what we have done is,
even though there is a solution, the real translations,
that is a mapping between VPN and MPN, is
remembered in the shadow page table. Which may be
the hardware page table if the processor is using the
page table for its address translation or it could be the TLB. In either case,
the hypervisor is going to install the translation from VPN to MPN into the TLB
and the hardware page table. So now
we basically bypassed the guess operating system's page
table in order to to the translation because
every time a process generates a virtual address.
We are not going through the guest operating
system to do the translation, but so long as
the translation has already been installed in the TLB
and the hardware page table. The hypervisor without the
intervention of the guest operating system can translate
the virtual page number of a user level process
running on top of the guest operating system. Lyrically
to the machine based number. Using the TLB and
the hardware page table. So this is
a trick to make atis translation efficient because
it's extremely crucial that on every memory
access, we don't go through the guest top
rating system to do the address translation,
it's just not acceptable. And this is the
trick that is used in VMware ESX server
that is implemented on top of Intel hardware.